salut à tous pour cette première
chronique politique je vous propose de
traiter d'un sujet d'actualité à savoir
les trahisons et reniements réelle ou
supposée du parti socialiste depuis son
accession au pouvoir en 2002 c'est parti
j'en tire les conclusions politiques
[Musique]
pour de nombreux sympathisants et
électeurs socialistes vous faites
peut-être partie vient de toi quelqu'un
qui ne l'en est une trahison des valeurs
de gauche
il faut dire que la politique du
gouvernement depuis quatre ans a de quoi
désespérer la plupart des réformes
économiques et sociales
initialement été soutenu par la droite
et le medef la stratégie pour relancer
la croissance est basé sur la baisse de
charges pour les entreprises
c'est donc une stratégie de l'offre
typiquement associé à la droite
habituellement à côté de cela la
croissance elle même est au plus bas
le chômage lui reste toujours au plus
haut le tout fait monter le front
national
donc oui quand on est de gauche de très
vite voir la politique du gouvernement
comme une trahison trahison des
promesses électorales d'abord mais aussi
et surtout une trahison des valeurs et
de l'éthique de la gauche dans cette
première chronique politique je vous
propose de prendre un peu de champ de
dépasser le constat d'électeurs déçus
pour chercher les raisons profondes qui
font qu il faut pouvoir le ps déçoit ses
électeurs au point que ceux-ci la vivent
comme une trahison
pour cela il faut comprendre quelles
sont les structures intellectuelle de la
gauche quels sont les rapports qui les
lie entre elles
le mieux est de remonter jusqu'à la
naissance de la troisième république car
c'est à partir de cette époque les
structures actuelles de la gauche se
sont progressivement mis en place
au début de la troisième république les
années 1800 glisse de grandes tendances
s'affrontent en france au niveau
parlementaire
la gauche et la droite alors vous allez
me dire ça change pas beaucoup d
aujourd'hui et bien puisque cette gauche
et cette droite sont extrêmement
différentes de celles qu'on connaît de
nos jours la droite à l'époque qui a
constitué deux monarchistes qui veulent
revenir l'ancien régime et de
bonapartiste qui veulent revenir à l'
empire
ces deux courants ont en commun de
vouloir un régime dynastique avec un
pouvoir fort de l'autre côté la gauche
est constitué de républicains alors non
pas ces républicains là à l'époque le
terme générique qui désigne aucun parti
spécifiquement et encore moins un parti
de droite
à l'époque ces républicains sont des
libéraux qui veulent des réformes
donnant plus de liberté aux citoyens et
sont guidés par des principes comme le
progrès et la liberté individuelle
il se situe dans la tradition de la
révolution française et des lumières
il se divise en deux courants un courant
modéré deep opportuniste car prêt à
s'allier à la droite quand il le faut et
un courant intransigeant appelé radical
ces radicaux constituent alors l'extrême
gauche parlementaire extrême gauche très
différente de celle d'aujourd'hui exxon
anticapitalisme révolutionnaire car à
l'époque la politique et un veston du
riche et ces radicaux qui sont
progressistes ne sont pas d'extrême
gauche comme on l'entend de nos jours
ils veulent par exemple la laïcisation
de l'état
l'école gratuite et obligatoire le droit
d'association ou encore l'impôt sur le
revenu
ces revendications qu'ils finiront par
exemple tenir et sont un peu les pertes
de notre république
pour preuve on connaît tous certains de
leurs noms ledru rollin gambetta
clemenceau et oui tout s'est donc l'on
croise au coin des rues sur le fronton
des écoles publiques qui n'ont pas
oublié le sens ce sont des républicains
radicaux
peut-être qu'un jour l'extrême gauche
actuelle rebrab cyr pouvoir et qu'on
aura alors des avenues arlette laguiller
ou des collèges olivier besancenot
toujours est il que la gauche dans les
années 1870 ce sont ces républicains le
socialisme lui est alors révolutionnaire
anti capitaliste et à de tout autres
terrains d'action et de développement
comme par exemple les seuls cas où
diverses sectes politique mais il est
extrêmement peu représentés à
l'assemblée nationale il ne s'est
d'ailleurs pas s'il devait faire de
l'opposition révolutionnaire ou bien
proposer des réformes sociales mais
entre les années 1880 et 1920 socialisme
et de radicalisme vont être amenés à se
rapprocher
tout d'abord parce que les deux courants
ont une forme d'idéal progressiste en
commun ils sont pour l'émancipation
individus pour une certaine forme de
justice sociale
et puis à l'époque du fait des
événements et ce séisme va se convertir
la défense de la république
il faut se rappeler qu'au 19e siècle la
france a connu pas moins de six régime
il se trouve que dans les deux dernières
décennies du siècle la république alors
naissante et se prépare plusieurs
affaires d'envergure dont la droite
prend un prétexte pour déstabiliser la
jeune république
il ya d'abord le christ boulangiste qui
réunit derrière la figure du général
boulanger tout ce que la nouvelle
république débecte ce qui va de certains
socialistes jusqu'au bonnart schiste il
ensuite la sphère de panama est une
affaire de corruption qui va toucher une
grande partie des politiques de l'époque
il y en fin la sphère dreyfus qui va
nous intéresser particulièrement pour
voir le rapprochement entre le
socialisme et la gauche pour rappel
alfred dreyfus ou capitaine dans l'armée
est accusée d'espionnage au profit de
l'allemagne parce que juifs et donc pas
assez français aux yeux de certains dès
le début les radicaux vont s'engager
dans le camp de réfugiés pour eux il est
normal de défendre un homme victime
d'une injustice
les socialistes eux l'on hésité avant de
s'engager alors pourquoi dit il et bien
parce qu'à l'époque l'idéologie
socialiste est structurée par la théorie
de l'aide des classes et dans le cadre
de cette lutte des classes l' affaire
dreyfus que dreyfus soit innocent ou non
est une affaire interne à la bourgeoisie
il n'est pas censé concerner le
prolétariat dont se revendique le
socialisme
néanmoins sous l'impulsion de certains
leaders comme jaurès le mouvement
socialiste va finir par prendre fait et
cause pour dreyfus
si aujourd'hui cela peut nous paraître
anodin il s'agit en fait à l'époque
d'une véritable révolution idéologique
en fait les socialistes l'ont intégré à
leur corpus idéologique la défense des
droits de l'homme à l'instar des
radicaux alors qu'il considérait jusque
là les droits de l'homme comme des
droits purement formelle au service de
la bourgeoisie cette agitation de la
droite qui est donc l'occasion pour les
radicaux et les socialistes de se
retrouver dans des combats communs
cette lutte commune pour la république
et les droits de l'homme préparent le
terrain des alliances dans les urnes qui
se concrétiseront dans la première
moitié du 20e siècle au début du 20e
siècle
la gauche a donc changé qui ne sont plus
les républicains radicaux et les
opportunistes mais les radicaux et le
socialisme
les opportunistes eux sont rejetés vers
la droite et on devenir de fait le
centre
cette nouvelle alliance entre le
radicalisme et socialisme a créé une
ambiguïté qui persistera jusqu'à nos
jours sur ce qu'est la gauche
on regroupe alors sous le même terme
deux idéologies extrêmement différentes
le socialisme se réfère pour marxisme et
à la lutte des classes quand le
radicalisme lui serait faire pour
lumière et à la révolution française
le socialisme est tourné vers les
classes populaires notamment les classes
populaires industriels le prolétariat en
le radicalisme lui est tourné vers les
classes moyennes et supérieures
le socialisme à battre le système
capitaliste que ce soit par des réformes
par la révolution quand le radicalisme
nuit seulement la compagnie et comme si
utiliser le même terme pour vous paie
deux idéologies extrêmement différents
ne suffisait pas pour créer la confusion
en 1920 d'avoir une dernière étape dans
l'apparition de la gauche actuelle le
parti socialiste se fracture au congrès
de tours avec d'un côté et soutient
l'urss naissant partisans de la
révolution qui vont fonder le parti
communiste français et de l'autre côté
les socialistes réformiste qui eux vont
rester au sein du parti socialiste
cette scission au sein de mouvements
socialistes pas clarifié le rapport à la
révolution
alors qu'avant révolutionnaire et
réformistes été mélangés au sein du même
parti à partir de 1920
on a d'un côté les révolutionnaires et
de l'autre côté les réformistes qui
veulent une transformation de la société
par des réformes graduelles
à partir de 1920 en incluant les
radicaux on a donc une gauche
constituées aux trois blocs aux options
politiques extrêmement différente et au
sein de laquelle les rapports sont
souvent très compliqué cette
segmentation de la gauche est toujours
valable aujourd'hui
même si ce ne sont plus les mêmes
parties qui portaient sur une solution
politique aujourd'hui le socialisme
révolutionnaire est porté par l'extrême
gauche trotskiste le socialisme
réformiste lui par le front de gauche
est une petite partie du parti
socialiste et le radicalisme lui est
présent majoritairement au parti
socialiste et au parti radical de gauche
si on se place dans une optique
socialiste oui il est évident que le ps
a trahi la gauche depuis quatre ans un
gouvernement mais une politique
d'accompagnement du système qui va bien
souvent jusqu à détricoter des acquis
sociaux initialement acquis par la
gauche est en fait c'est confondre
gauche et socialisme si on fait
abstraction des réformes sociales et
qu'on regarde plutôt des réformes
sociétales voit que la le gouvernement
est toujours dans la tradition
émancipatrice de la gauche je pense en
particulier au mariage gay cette loi les
opposants l'ont perçu comme une
diversion pour ne pas parler des échecs
de la politique économique c'est à mon
avis très mal connaître la gauche car
pour le coup toutes les composantes de
la gauche qui était d'accord et cette
réforme du ps pour npa en passant par
les mélenchonistes et les communistes
ici extrême gauche a protesté dans cette
affaire c'est parce que cette loi
n'avait pas assez loin à son goût
si toutes ces composantes ont soutenu le
projet de loi c'est bel et bien parce
qu'il se situe dans une logique
d'extension des droits individuels dans
la plus pure tradition des courants
adecco républicains et socialistes et ce
quoi qu'on puisse penser par ailleurs de
cette loi libéralisme au niveau sociétal
et gestion du système audio économique
très clairement la politique du
gouvernement est inspiré du raid
kahnisme même si aujourd'hui on est
plutôt social libéral d'ailleurs quand
on regarde quelles sont les grandes
figures qui inspire les membres du
gouvernement bien souvent ce sont des
radicaux par exemple valls son grand
modèle c'est georges clemenceau qui
était radical
ce n'est pas jaurès blum ont un autre
exemple c'est jean marie le guen membre
du ps secrétaire d'état aux relations
avec le parlement
franck de manuel valls qui a récemment
écrit un petit ouvrage intitulé la
gauche qui vient cet ouvrage ne parle
pas de socialisme d'ailleurs le mot
revient à lui-même très peu de textes
par contre parle de valeurs de la
république flexisécurité adaptation au
monde de demain
là encore on est dans une optique bien
plus radicale que socialiste un comble
quand on sait que le livre a été édité
par la fondation jean jaurès
ce n'est pas un hasard si aujourd'hui
les derniers vraiment soutenir le
gouvernement soumet radicaux de gauche
en fait ce qui était trahi ce n'est pas
la gauche en général mais les valeurs
socialistes et la question à se poser en
fait c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui ceux qui
dirigent au parti socialiste on se
revendique de la tradition radicale et
non la tradition socialiste
la réponse est simple pendant plusieurs
décennies après une guerre mondiale le
socialisme est hégémonique à gauche au
point que de gauche et socialisme mas
deviennent des synonymes
le radicalisme nuit à l'occasion disparu
ce qui fait que des gens qui se serait
initialement identifiés au radicalisme
on était obligé d'endosser un discours
socialiste pour pouvoir accéder aux
responsabilités
c'est comme ça qu'on a une terrain comme
président
le président a porté par le parti
socialiste et le parti communiste élu
sur un programme clairement socialiste
alors que lui ne l'a jamais été
aujourd'hui malgré les évolutions
sociologiques qui font par exemple qu'il
ya moins d'ouvriers clinique selon lui
son meilleur
ce qui rend les discours de rupture
moins pertinents une grande partie de
l'électorat de gauche est toujours
attaché au discours il suit la tradition
socialiste et ce alors que le parti
socialiste lui a abandonné cette
idéologie
en fait aujourd'hui un décalage complet
entre ce qui est théoriquement le parti
son histoire le discours qu'il véhicule
en temps de campagne électorale et la
politique qu'il mène une fois au pouvoir
ils ces éclairages qui crée chez les
électeurs de gauche le sentiment d'avoir
été trahis sentiment tout à fait
légitime puisque le ps même pas la
politique pour laquelle il a été élu
l'enjeu dans les prochaines années à
gauche ça va être la clarification du
discours la période historique qui
faisait que ce scellé syndicaux
cohabiter au sein du même parti sous
l'hégémonie socialiste est révolu
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui certains
commencent nous plaît parlez de la
gauche mais des gauches et chacun va
devoir maintenant choisir entre deux
discours d'un côté un discours radical
et l'autre côté discours socialiste
c'est-à-dire entre clemenceau d'un côté
et je reste de l'autre et bien voilà
cette première vidéo touche à sa fin
j'espère que vous aurez apporté des
éléments de compréhension et de
réflexion sur l'état actuel de la gauche
et pour ma part il me reste plus qu'à
vous dire à la prochaine
[Musique]